bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
du colorado
kenneth zimmerman merci de répondre à
nos questions comment est-ce que vous
depuis le colorado là vous avez vécu
cette cérémonie d'investiture
écoutez nous sommes presque la moitié
des américains qui pensent toujours que
paris est devenu président par un
procédure illégale et
anticonstitutionnelle
évidemment il y maintenant président qui
va gouverner tant bien que mal mais ce
discours d'unité c'est une farce pour la
plupart entre nous ça c'est vous la côte
et domestique intérieur américain sur la
politique étrangère à avoir beaucoup de
défis dans les semaines et mois à venir
à mon avis qu'ils vont venir d'abord de
la chine la corée du nord
et surtout surtout de l'iran et on sait
que il est absolument obstiné à rentrer
dans le pacte à mon avis ça va être une
catastrophe
c'est avec nous kenneth timerman netqin
estime erman comment est-ce que vous
jugez la sortie aujourd'hui de donald
trump donc que vous connaissez bien il a
quitté la maison blanche aux alentours
de 14h15
il a pris l'hélicoptère en survolant le
capitole et puis ensuite il est arrivé à
la base militaire d'andrews dans la
banlieue de washington où il a prononcé
un ultime discours comment est ce que
vous l'avez trouvé ce discours
écoutez je pense que dans notre offre
maintenant va fonder une nouvelle partie
politique un parti de patriotes nous
sommes 74 millions kitty l'ont soutenu
pendant cette élection et ont des caries
de manière ou d'une autre par dont vous
faites allusion à ce qu'il a dit dans ce
discours je reviendrai d'une manière ou
d'une autre c'est ça une voix 2024 c'est
ce qu'il a en ligne directement
il va revenir en 2024 en tête de
nouveaux partis politiques qui sert en
partie de patriotes et ça va poser un
grand problème pour le parti républicain
qui dans les jours qui viennent pas
probablement dans le sauna pour le pitch
ce quelque chose d'absolument incroyable
destructive et à mon avis qui va faire
éclater le parti républicain aux états
unis connaissent timerman
restez avec nous selon vous à quoi
est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre entre
washington et moscou
dans ces prochains mois et écoutez je
pense que toutes les hostilités que les
démocrates avaient manifesté depuis
quatre ans envers moscou va diminuer et
pourquoi parce qu'ils savent
pertinemment eux-mêmes que la russie ne
serait pas intervenu lors de l'élection
tout cela est mon éducation de la
compagnie aérienne le sait maintenant
par des doigts qui montrent qu'ils
étaient déclassifiés par dans notre pays
par les agences de renseignement donc je
pense que les relations entre les
etats-unis et la russie vont retenir
plutôt normal et on revient en retour en
arrière par contre c'est avec toi chine
qu'on va voir la plus de différences
bail de 10 durant la campagne que la
chine n'est pas un ennemi damon
adversaires mais un concurrent en
concurrents à mon avis il va très vite
levé toutes les mesures économiques déjà
rif et autres mesures envers la chine et
cela va accélérer l'expansion de
l'économie chinoise
merci thierry jam et emmène pour cette
réponse mais restez avec nous a
évidemment pour cette cérémonie
d'investiture selon vous qu'est né ce
timerman à quoi est-ce qu'il faut
s'attendre dans les futures relations
entre joe biden que l'on voit ici à
l'image avec avec emmanuel macron écouté
il est évident que brydon c'est un
internationaliste c'est quelqu'un qui
croit profondément dans une système
global de sécurité et donc vous allez
voir engager un cam a dit le président
au maximum mais il faut quand même
comprendre que entre le président
trompait marchetti le président macro il
avait des bonnes relations
il avait une coopération quand même est
tendue donc il y a
pas de gros de grands troubles entre la
france et les états unis durant ces
quarante dernières années c'est que il y
avait des différences de politiques en
profondeur notamment sur l'iran et je
vois par an par andres que la france
elle-même revient sur sa position
vis-à-vis le pacte nucléaire avec l'iran
et reconnaît le danger que pose l'iran
au monde entier pas seulement israël
mais le monde entier donc moi je pense
que nous allons vers un retour à la
normale merci cana cymerman d'avoir
répondu à nos questions en direct du du
colorado je rappelle que vous êtes donc
un ancien conseiller à donald trump pour
ce conseiller aux affaires étrangères de
l'ex président américain lors de la
campagne présidentielle de 2016 merci
beaucoup
cana cymerman d'avoir répondu à nos
questions